when the chief start training camp
receiver tyree kill will be there we
know that from friday's decision by the
league to not suspend him at all not to
even discipline him in any way for the
various potential violations of the
personal conduct policy but that's not
the end of it as it relates to hill's
future with the chiefs
unrelated to whether or not he'll be
disciplined suspended whatever and again
for now the answer is he won't be with
that door open for the possibility of
additional evidence not available to the
nfl coming to light at some point down
the road but let's assume nothing ever
comes of it
as it relates to tyreek hill's contract
there's still a chance that he won't be
a member of the team over the long term
and here's why
they already started negotiating a deal
that happened before the off-field
incident kind of took center stage for
the chief's offseason program
but before things really hit full boil
jay glazer of fox who also writes a
weekly mail bag column for the athletic
he pointed out he had heard some trade
rumblings at the outset of free agency
about tyree kill now
if it's not related to what possibly was
coming down the pipeline for tyreek hill
that means that it may have arisen from
the financial demands that were being
made on hill's behalf and you can make
the argument the guy's worth 20 million
dollars a year or more but when you're
the chiefs and you have to pay guys like
patrick mahomes and chris jones and
other great players who are either on
the team or will be on the team in the
future you have to make some tough
decisions
and with michael hardman there drafted
in round two out of georgia and
ostensibly at the time he was picked the
replacement for tyree kill in the short
term
maybe hardman's the long-term
replacement and hardman gives the chiefs
the opportunity to really study what he
can do and he's drawn some favorable
comparisons to guys like hill and
deshawn jackson from chiefs coach andy
reid
if hardman shows the kind of flashes
that we saw from tyree kill his rookie
year because remember hill didn't
explode as a rookie we saw some great
things in special teams but we didn't
see him as that kind of contributor he's
been in 2017 and 2018 for the chiefs
offensively if we see enough flashes
from hardman it allows the chiefs to
move on from hill after the season to do
what they did with d ford last year tag
hill and trade him and then let hardman
basically take over the tyree kill roll
if that's what they choose to do and
keep this in mind hill may want 20
million a year hardman's under contract
for four years at a total of less than
five million dollars so look the
business of football is going to be very
relevant for the kansas city chiefs
because we know patrick mahomes is going
to get his and it's going to be a
record-setting deal they have to be
careful how much money they they spend
on other players on the roster in order
to have enough great players around
mahomes and enough depth to deal with
the inevitable injury so it could be
that by the time it's all said and done
the chiefs decide to tag and trade hill
and make me call hardman the new tyree
kill in the kansas city chiefs offense
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports